the Joe Rogan experience the flip is
like Dylan who I still find myself like
when you watch the new Scorsese have you
seen that thing rolling rolling thunder'
it's really worth watching that or the
original scripts ad doc about him one
nodirectionhome like here's this guy
he's like in his early 20s and they're
coming at him with all this like voice
you generation all this stuff and he's
like that's nothing I can relate to man
you know and he's going like I can't
help wondering if Lenny Bruce loved
Dylan him I don't know that but I would
think that Lenny Bruce was tuned into
Dylan because Dylan's thing was like
don't ask me what it means man I wrote
it I you know I don't know what it means
what what do you think it means he was
just constantly going
buzz off man I'm not picking it apart
for you I'm not gonna pick it apart for
you I'm not gonna like buy into this
stuff you're putting at me and how did
he eat he was 20 20 21 years old like
who resists who resists people falling
all over them to call him great when
they're that age nobody right nobody has
that kind of flexibility sensibility to
go
everything you're bringing at me is
gonna be bad for me and I it is like
watch that if you watch those interviews
with him when he's that age it's pretty
astonishing because to your point like
you're like a thoughtful act whatever I
look at him and I'm like nobody has that
discipline at that age
it's amazing how uniquely qualified he
was for that position at that point in
time and that very strange tumultuous
time in history as well and not only
that right at the moment that that like
Joni Baez brings him out on the stage at
the Newport Folk Festival and basically
goes this is the prince this is I anoint
you he's the one he's neo he's the he is
the one and the next year he doesn't
even take one year to go to go let me
just let me just lean into your love the
next year he comes with an electric
guitar and plugs it in at the Newport
Folk Festival and people start screaming
in agony like going what are you doing
like you're Bob Dylan you're the
folk you can't plug in a guitar and
people are like running to try to cut
his chords with an ax in this thing like
that's how much of a betrayal and he's
like there's people yelling traitor at
him and he's going I don't believe you
you know I think you're a liar like and
he's turning around to Robbie Robertson
and go and play it loud I mean the guy
is so punk rock wow he's so totally punk
rock he he was his punk rock as anybody
ever I think he probably had to be just
to resist what they were trying to box
him into yeah and by but there's never
been anybody who was more like oh you
like what I'm doing I'm gone I'm over
here like enjoy you're gonna not like it
because you like what I just did now
where I'm going you're gonna be
discombobulated and upset and eventually
you're gonna catch up and then when you
catch up I'm gonna move on to something
else like it's it's really it really is
amazing is amazing cuz how many people
do you know in any of the things we all
do who get a taste of the thing and
don't like lean into it for a while
right like who don't kind of go well
this feels good you know maybe I'll just
hang out right here and
[Music]
[Applause]